[Music]
they tried to hide us they put banks up
around the sides eye fences around us
they're excluding us from society not
including us with the forgotten people
this gypsy end traveler site is one of
hundreds across the uk
it's wedged next to a recycling plant
and a fire brigade training school that
sometimes smothers it in smoke but for
the people who live here the site is
crucial to their identity
bricks and mortar is no good to a
traveler when we're living in else's we
we're locked in like we're in a bird in
a cage
but gypsies and travelers face another
constraint financial exclusion
an address here can make it
extraordinarily difficult to get home
insurance car insurance or even a bank
account
and that means some of the most
marginalized people in britain face
higher risks and higher costs
and have less chance of living a stable
prosperous life
in this film we're going to look at how
gypsies and travelers are fighting to
overcome these issues
and what the problem reveals about our
financial institutions
and our society
the next plot up after this one
that's my sister-in-law
so it's basically we got we got a lot of
family on it
and it's a it's a beautiful thing to
have family around you terry green is
one of tens or maybe hundreds of
thousands of people in england who call
themselves gypsies or travelers
he spent 28 years trying to move out of
his council house to somewhere like this
site near mayr's field in east sussex we
used to live in a lay by there before
that site was built for free year we
lived in that lay boy and then we moved
back off and i went traveling
and then we came back to this site again
and then the council came and told us
that we couldn't live
together as a family unit and they give
us an ultimatum that i get off or both
of us get off
and they moved us off of there
they gave us an house
and for 28 years i've been
i was trying to get out of that house
i just didn't want to live there at all
yet after greene won his battle to find
a pitch in a caravan site he found
himself embroiled in a new struggle
green's motor insurance provider
cancelled his cover as soon as he
switched his address to a gypsy site i
phoned 54
insurance companies
and they turned me down flat
because
when they said where do you live
the address when i said a caravan saw it
no no no
um and that's all i had 54 times we
can't get insurance on our caravans
we can't get home to own contents
insurance
we can't get nothing
they sent the letter saying we canceled
your insurance because you didn't tell
us the truth where you lived
i said but i told you
it was a caravan site but you didn't
tell us it was a gypsy side
this kind of discrimination makes it
difficult to live and work the thing is
when you're traveling man you know it's
you're brought up not to just do one
thing you've got to learn
more than one job so you could be doing
roofing through work brick and
tarmacking you know you've got to learn
put your hands around everything you
know it's not just one thing in life
because everything every day
everything's getting harder unless
you've got a solid a solid performance
job
that's it
and that's that's why we
we basically
want the kids to get a good education
a good education because
our wildlife is diminishing 20 years ago
similar problem very hard for housing
association tenants to get contents
insurance for their homes they were
routinely being told we don't provide we
don't provide
the difference being there were four
million of them so eventually the
insurers thought there's a market here
we should devise a specialist product
and some of the smaller groups went into
that market and it's now quite
successfully served the problem for
gypsy travellers is that as a group
they're not as large and also they're
very marginalized in society i would
love it for a fintech company to come
along and champion their rights and say
yes
these people are just as entitled to
access financial products and insurance
as anyone else and the way that they
live their lives shouldn't be a factor
in that
accounts like greens are very familiar
to emma nuttle of friends families and
travelers a group that works against
discrimination really on every indices
gypsy and travellers face severe social
exclusion gypsum travelers have the
highest infant mortality rates the
lowest life expectancy the lowest
educational
attainment out of any groups in the uk
and financial exclusion is is another
area that yes gypsum travelers do face
a lot of our clients are homeless and
nomadic gypsies and travellers because
of the shortage of authorized sites to
stop on so they don't have a fixed
address they're statutory homeless and
it does present difficulties getting
bank accounts the client of ours went
into an insurance broker on the high
street to get insurance for the caravan
that she lived in and she had illiteracy
issues so the insurance broker filled
out the form for her and there was a
question on the form which said do you
live on a gypsy site well the broker
didn't realize that she was a traveler
and never asked the question i mean that
was an illegal discriminatory question
but
so the client didn't know that the
question was even on the form and later
down the line she had a burglary and she
went to the insurance company to pay out
and they refused her then we did
actually refer
the case to the financial ombudsman and
she won the case and she got paid
in general financial inclusion is is a
policy area where there's actually a
great deal of political consensus it's a
good thing
and there's a great deal of appetite to
do more of it you know for sort of
fairly obvious reasons right on the
labor side they see it as an issue of
you know social justice equality of
opportunity on the conservative side
they feel that you know
people you know getting that first first
step on the financial ladder is an
important part of people becoming
conservative the thing that uk politics
struggles to process when they're
thinking about how to help people from
uh you know gibson will travel the
background isn't we have this sort of um
in some ways quite liberal approach of
look
if you have a you know
whatever you want to do once you've
closed the door of your house fine right
provided that you buy into the central
british thing of having your house with
a door that you close find it and
something i think about the nomadic
lifestyle sort of
breaks that british assumption about
what liberal integration looks like and
i think that's not just in finance but
in general one of the reasons why
people from a gypsy roman traveler
background are so poorly served in the
uk
the problems affect groups that have
long been among the most marginalized in
society in britain and europe more
generally for centuries
in mainland europe the persecution
reached its nadia in the nazis killing
of hundreds of thousands of roma as
they're often called in europe during
the holocaust
[Music]
brian belton an academic and writer of
romani gypsy descent
tries to unpick what he says is a very
complex picture of labels and identity
among gypsies and travelers in the uk
and ireland
gypsies whose name is short for egyptian
but whose origin is uncertain
first appeared in the historical record
around 1500 belton says
irish travellers are a more recent
edition
some families arrived as recently as the
1970s to build motorways and ended up
traveling because of the challenges of
finding housing
they came along first of all with the
building of the canals probably before
that but also the east london docks were
basically built by irish labor
then there was the railways and the
roads so these waves of irish uh
immigration into this country
brought with them what you would call a
traveler population and some of them
became travelers because of the access
to housing in the 60s and 70s was pretty
terrible
but belton goes on some discrimination
takes the form of generalized prejudice
against anyone who lives in the caravan
there is particular suffering during the
coronavirus pandemic he says
when the pandemic came around the site
owners not all of them but appreciable
numbers of them started to enforce the
holiday rent rules and were throwing
these people off the sites
for three months so you have to do
something something within the
you know the bylaws so you can't be
there for three months of the year
um
you see so they're they're a group of
people that are given a problem because
of the way they they've not necessarily
chosen to live some of them have but
some of them have been obliged to live
in this this way
there are separate stereotypes and
prejudices according to belton
concerning gypsies as an ethnic group
gypsies are expected to be attracted to
work laying tarmac the black stuff and
to be naturally gifted boxers
belton is proud of his gypsy heritage
but he doesn't see any reason why he
should desert his comfortable tennis
house for a caravan
i get called a traitor because i don't
live in a caravan that i should have is
my blood to be nomadic
and my argument is well there's other
ways to be nomadic than we go around the
country i'm a gypsy with a library i'm a
gypsy with a phd i'm a gypsy who went to
go into university you know that doesn't
get associated i don't fit the the nice
raggle taggle gypsy mode you know
and that's the same sort of myth it's a
similar sort of myth that i've got to
live in a caravan most gypsies in europe
do not live in caravans
the bottom line he says is that gypsies
travelers and anyone living in nomadic
life are treated as outsiders
britain is still a colonial society
so what we do is we portray people as
them and us
they become the pariahs they become the
ones who are to blame that lower group
it's happened in other societies with
other groups of people it's a kind of
caste system in a way
and then we prune that as gypsies say
yes that's correct we're not like you
but even playing a bit more by
mainstream society's rules doesn't
necessarily resolve all the financial
issues facing gypsies and travelers
most most of the people on here gypsies
but there's a few travelers on as well
at the site where he lives on the edge
of darlington in northeast england
billy welsh one of the community's best
known figures explains why so many
gypsies end up self-employed the reason
why we're all self-employed is is
because nobody will employees one of my
sons have just finished college totally
out of the norm and he went and he
passed for flying colours and then he
had to do a year's work experience
and so he had to be employed by another
a qualified plumber or a company
and uh for a year or two so he got work
experience like being an apprentice
and um
he couldn't get nobody would employ him
absolutely nobody at all would employ
he says tensions between gypsies and
settled communities
including problems over the setting up
of caravan sites
often stem from mutual misunderstanding
unusually at the site in darlington the
local council doesn't run the facility
directly but has contracted the work out
to welsh
he says such arrangements have an
important role to play in improving the
lot of gypsy and traveller communities
sometimes people from acceptable
community can misunderstand us or vice
versa we can misunderstand them during
and it causes sometimes can cause
friction but darlington company council
understand that and they understand by
working with the gypsies and travelers
like myself
and
coordinating things and running things
by me they'll say billy we've got this
idea
and what do you think of this i'll say
yeah it's a good idea but don't do it
maybe in that direction do it this way
tweak it a little bit do it and it'll
work better to remain bleed by working
with the gypsies and travellers it's
worked well
[Music]
yet the residents of sites elsewhere
like this one in bow in east london
still believe they are being shut out of
the system and feel a deep sense of
injustice
[Music]
marian mahoney a traveler living here
can't understand why it's impossible for
her to ensure the contents of the chalet
and fixed caravans she inhabits here
they don't find a caravan or a static
home as safe as water wood bricks and
mortar
and some people do find it very
difficult to get their home insurance
is it even
insurance like for your funeral if they
find it very bad that our travelers just
don't bother with funeral plans and
things like that because even then
the the funeral directors are said to
well you might move away
you know they should give them an
ultimatum if they do move away that will
always be there for them if they want to
do that you know almost anything in life
that higher purchase
a very very hardcore purchase
and very very hard to get like
anything alone or anything like that
very very hard
the association of british insurers the
industry's trade body insists that its
members don't discriminate on the basis
of customers ethnicity
they said
one of the elements insurers need to
accurately assess risk when considering
cover is a postcode as this provides a
range of information about the area from
flood risk to the volume of road traffic
accidents
there were products available for people
who couldn't provide a postcode they
went on we'd encourage anyone looking
for such cover to contact an insurance
broker who may be able to help they said
insurers will always abide by the
equality act they added
on a data level
any insurer has to price risk now if
there's no data available on the risk of
insuring people in a particular area or
on a gypsy traveler site
one insurer pulls out of the market
another does that date is getting
thinner and thinner so you can see why
it's convenient for them to say well we
can't price this risk therefore we can't
provide cover to this group who could be
high risk and maybe it's not a market
that they feel they need to be in i
would throw down the gauntlet to the
insurance industry and say you've seen
the film show us that you're not
discriminating against this group of
people all of the piecemeal excuses that
you've given for not providing cover for
certain postcodes saying that there's a
date of blackout you can't price the
risk
invent a product team up with a fintech
look at the innovation that's going on
in the market elsewhere nothing is
impossible show that this is a problem
that you care about solving rather than
just turning customers away there is
very little
sort of thought and policy attention
given outside the community itself to
how you might facilitate better access
to you know
finance to schools to what have you
while still facilitating people's uh
willingness to live as they wish when is
the government you want insurance
companies or indeed any financial
services to do something that they do
not want to do
because they think it is financially
risky that is where you should use your
capacity as the lender of last resort to
incentivize and change the calculation
then
it's much better to create the
conditions where an insurance company
feels relaxed and comfortable with
providing insurance to people from a
gypsy roamer or traveller background and
it is to have a situation in which the
government goes well we don't care if
you're comfortable with doing it we're
going to force you into doing it anyway
warren lee a support worker for london
gypsies and travellers says there ought
to be tighter regulation of the
financial services industry to alleviate
the problems
yes there needs to be regulation but
also
there needs to be
you know
legislation or internal pressure as well
from within these organizations
from people within these organizations
to say this isn't right what we're doing
we're not
we're there's a family living in
greenwich
that have no insurance on their entire
home
or any of their cars
and we're not going to give it to them
and neither will the next company or
neither or the next company so there
needs to be something coming from within
that sector
to put a check on it there's only so
much that regulation auditing and stuff
can find really we need the people that
work within the financial sector to say
not on my watch
one of the few recent victories for
gypsies and travellers was a result of
whistleblowing lee points out a worker
pontons and operator of holiday camps
told the media that the company used a
list of names associated with the
traveler community
as the basis for refusing some bookings
but people at the site in bow see the
challenges of getting insurance as part
of a wider pattern
that everything is made a bit more
complicated and a bit more expensive for
gypsies and travelers
frances jones one of marion's neighbors
says her family had little difficulty
getting traders insurance for the
vehicles used in her partner's scrap
metal business
until they changed their address from a
normal house to the bow traveler side
i went to renew it and that's when i got
told sorry we can't do your insurance
the insurance goes up like literally a
thousand pound a year when they realize
you live in the caravan site so you
won't afford it to pay for it i face a
lot because we're trying to work proper
legalize ourselves and when we're trying
to legalize ourselves we get bounced off
like i just think like you're done great
at you because you're trying to be legal
if you get if you try and put yourself
on um insurance for
um driving a motor with scrap you have
to have a scrap license you have to go
through the government to get that then
you have to go to the government and uh
prove that you're doing this
then automatically you have to tax
register yourself that's to just get
insurance
her biggest worry though is for the next
generation they won't be able to get
married it won't be like to get money
tomorrow getting extra pitched won't get
insurance on their car but when they
come to 17 18 past the driving house
what's a traveler girl and boy does
they're getting a guy they can't get in
the car they've got a car sitting there
and a driving license can't get no
insurance
so they're stuck in their
you know it's a very hard situation i've
been through it this issue of financial
exclusion it's not something that the
government should take its eye off
especially in the cost of living crisis
people who are on low incomes are
digitally excluded as well as
financially excluded and this was
becoming more and more of a problem as
our lives move online you need to have
money to have a laptop a smartphone a
broadband connection phone credit the
benefit system is digital first yet this
really isn't being recognized enough in
the corridors of power and for the
poorest financial literacy
knowing about the choices that you have
with your money is certainly a big part
of the issue but not having enough money
is probably a bigger problem
there is little dispute that the uk's
chip season travelers face a hard time
obtaining a whole range of financial
services
they have unusual difficulty getting
cars insured
they seldom have cover for the home
contents
simple products to spread the costs of
purchases are often out of reach
the community is organizing to curb
abuses
but the financial services industry
continues to insist there's no
fundamental problem
and that they can't help it if chip
season travelers are a poor financial
risk
that is like people like marion mahoney
and francis jones worried
they fear that any improvement for the
next generation
may be far more incremental
than the scale of the problem demands
[Music]